all right so another question from
someone that came to America from Europe
and wanted to know why can they eat
pasta and pizza in their country but not
in the US okay why is that because when
they eat these grains they it just makes
them feel really bloated and it's really
heavy in the digestive system yet when
they go back home it doesn't create that
effect okay the first thing is you
shouldn't be consuming bread pasta
cereal crackers biscuits pizza okay
because especially if you're doing keto
it's going to throw you off but I do
want to mention why you're going to have
more problems in America and that is
because in the US Canada in Britain they
fortify their grains okay they enrich
them with iron and certain B vitamins
all right here are the problems with
fortification let's start with iron
number one iron accumulates in your body
okay it can actually be very toxic to
the body when it starts building up
because the problem is your body is only
able to eliminate a very small amounts
of this iron each day like a little
thing it's a little more than one
milligram a day yet you can accumulate a
lot if you're consuming a lot of grains
and iron tends to be attracted to
damaged parts of the tissue like let's
say for example you have high insulin
created from all the pasta right and it
creates the damage in the artery wall or
your brain or your nervous system or the
kidney or other places like the pancreas
well the iron is going to be attracted
to those areas so iron is very oxidative
so it can create like a rusting effect
on your tissues and I'm going to do a
separate video just on iron but iron can
also disrupt your friendly bacteria in
your colon so when you consume this
product you're gonna feel very very
heavy in the gut now as far as the B
vitamins like especially b2 and b12
usually they're genetically modified in
fact the product Cheerios and Grape Nuts
just went non-gmo and if you notice that
they no longer fortify these grains
because it's almost impossible to know
for sure if it's GMO free
because even if they're making B
vitamins from yeast they're feeding the
yeast glucose which is from corn which
is GML and GMO foods are laced with
glyphosate and herbicide so that alone
will create a lot of problems in your GI
tract okay so in nutshell that's why
you're going to bloat when you consume
pasta or pizza or other grains in
America
all right but I'm not recommending
consuming grains or anything that's
fortified all right thanks for watching